l'italie politique en prise peut être
l'heure de l'équilibré de la morale
nouvelles élections présidentielles le
29 juin béguines et son gouvernement
malades de la cisjordanie
démissionnera t-il dimanche 12 députés
propose l'abolition de la peine de mort
le ministre de la justice n'exclut pas
un débat au parlement cet automne la
discrimination des femmes devant le
travail et le salaire
comment t'y mettre en terre les
messieurs bonsoir au delà de tous ces
titres il nous faut commencer par une
information qui est en notre possession
et que nous ne pouvions pas garder plus
longtemps sous le coude il s'agit d'une
véritable petite révolution dans les
méthodes d'observation de la planète et
c'est une invention française
les ingénieurs sont partis du principe
du ballon
c'est petit et ça n'a pas besoin de
voler très haut seulement le problème
c'est qu'un ballon ne restait jamais
bien longtemps en l'air ils ont donc
imaginé pour son énergie
l'utilisation des rayons du soleil après
un bon lancement
le ballon est pratiquement éternels ils
échappent aux radars et ses applications
sont proprement fantastique
on peut tout imaginer espionnage
affaires militaires et même puisque nous
sommes vendredi une simple observation
du trafic routier sur la france
ce jaillissement argentée qui s'envole
devant vous n'est pas un être vivant
mais presse il s'agit d'une montgolfière
française contrairement aux inventions
du xviiie siècle
aucun feu aucune flamme ne vient
soulever cette fragile enveloppe son
moteur c'est le soleil dans une base
spatiale lointaine quelques savants
français s'active au petit jour autour
du premier véhicule stratosphérique
uniquement mû par l'énergie solaire
manoeuvrable grâce au clap est situé au
dessus et en dessous de la montgolfière
le matériau utilisé pour les eaux du
ballon est plus mince que du papier de
chocolat c'est du mylar recouvert
d'aluminium qualités spatiales lâché
tout aidé par un peu de gaz ultra léger
l'hélium la montgolfière monte lentement
elle ne ressemble pas du tout ballon
gonflé en fait au décollage
cette montgolfière est pratiquement vide
elle se remplit d'air petit à petit au
fur et à mesure qu'elle montre le jour
l'enveloppent supérieur en mylar absorbe
fortement les rayons du soleil et donc
réchauffe l'air intérieur comme l'air
chaud a tendance à monter la
montgolfière ses lèvres
elle peut ainsi atteindre 20 ou 30 km
d'altitude
ce modèle expérimental emporte 50 kg
d'instruments de mesure les petits
ballons situé en dessous de la
montgolfière vous montre les
emplacements des nacelles qui peuvent
contenir des caméras des enregistreurs
des émetteurs radio et cetera
l'inventeur de ce véhicule
le service d'aéronomie du cnrs peut
l'utiliser pour étudier les variations
de la couche d'ozone et savoir comment
elle évolue et comment elle nous protège
des rayons ultraviolets du soleil
mais ce n'est pas tout la nuit il n'y a
pas de soleil et l'air se refroidit
alors cette fois ci la montgolfière va
capter la chaleur de la terre grâce à
son enveloppe inférieure de plastique
très fin du polyéthylène et ainsi de
jour comme de nuit elle peut se
maintenir en altitude pendant très
longtemps
lorsqu'elle est très hot la montgolfière
paraît bien rond bien gonfler le cnes
étudier la possibilité d'en faire une
plate forme de surveillance de la
pollution mais déjà des applications
d'observation intéresse les militaires
car étant donnée sa petite taille la
montgolfière solaire est pratiquement
indétectables
et voyez vous j'ai ici sur mon bureau la
maquette d'un autre voyageur de l'espace
qui lui est soviétique ses soyouz 29
lancers dans la nuit avec à son bord
deux cosmonautes soyouz va rejoindre la
station orbitale saliou de 6 il navigue
dans l'espace depuis neuf mois et ce
devrait être le prélude à une nouvelle
série d'activités à bord de sa luxe qui
peut recevoir simultanément deux équipes
de cosmonaute activités prévues l'étude
des alliages métalliques impossible à
obtenir sur terre et l'élaboration de
cristaux parfaitement
deuxième titre de l'actualité la
démission du président leone et en
italie vous avez vécu hier soir minute
par minute cette nouvelle péripétie de
la vie politique italienne et vous avez
d'ailleurs été les premiers bien
qu'habituée au drame nos voisins ont
tout de même ressenti péniblement cet
épilogue d'un scandale qui durait depuis
deux ans scandale à base de corruption
et de fraude fiscale
relancé en début de semaine par
l'hebdomadaire expresso en attendant la
désignation d'un nouveau président de la
république le 29 de ce mois est à minto
refund fanny le président du sénat qui
assure par intérim l'achat n'est pas
tout à fait comparable au watergate mais
enfin une fois encore et comme aux états
unis
c'est la presse qui a provoqué la
démission d'un chef de l'état un
journaliste italien qui dirige le
service politique de l'hebdomadaire de
gauche l'espresso a dénoncé le président
de la république
régulièrement avec conviction avec une
opiniâtreté déconcertante et je n'étais
jamais démenti selon seuls les terres
je n'étais jamais non jamais été
reportée car elles ont jamais parce que
je fais tout ça exactement sur des
documents ils sont des documents sur le
lac yves 2
bien immobilière sur le logo mans des
documents de procès lockheed omen seul
et comme on dit que la dénonciation des
taxes du président mais est-ce que
d'après vous c'est une preuve que la
démocratie italienne fonctionne bien oui
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
c'est presque les mêmes choses qui
passent et avec le président nixon amis
que je pense que le président d'élection
elle a fait les choses bien moins grave
que le président leone et j'espère qu'on
fait je veux je suis presque sûre qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec messieurs leone
il aura drogue effet moralisateur en
italie parce que je pense que d autres
politiciens qui sont mêlés dans des
choses
leclerc et vaut être un petit peu au
moins près d'or maintenant il faut aller
vite c'est l'article 86 de la
constitution qu'il prévoit le parlement
doit se réunir dans un délai de 15 jours
et installé un nouveau président au
palais du quirinale protégé par les
célèbres cuirassiers qui doit mesurer au
moins 1 mètre 90 le problème maintenant
est de savoir si le prochain président
de la république qui va s'installer dans
ce palais du quirinal sera démocrates
chrétiens comme giovanni lot ou bien
comme on dit un laïc c'est à dire
socialiste social démocrate ou
républicain ce sera en tout cas un test
décisif sur la volonté d'ouverture des
démocrates chrétiens surtout après
l'entrée des communistes dans la
majorité gouvernementale
cela dit ce problème est un peu formel
dans la mesure où en italie on a tout
fait pour réduire les pouvoirs du
président de la république qui disent on
n'a pas plus de pouvoir que les
présidents de la république française
sous la quatrième république laïque ou
démocrate chrétien
qui sont les candidats les mieux placés
du côté de la démocratie chrétienne il
ya tout d'abord le président du conseil
giulio andreotti
il ya aussi et ses actions sont
fortement en hausse benino zaccagnini le
secrétaire général de la démocratie
chrétienne honnête et suffisamment
populaire
il est enfin l'éternel candidat
malheureux à la présidence à minto les
fans fanny le président du sénat qui
assurera pendant une quinzaine de jours
la terrine de giovanni léonais parmi les
candidats laïcs ou gholam half
le président du parti républicain est le
mieux placé de toute façon rien n'est
joué
les parties vont se consulter pour
éviter que l'élection présidentielle ne
se transforme en marathon comme ce fut
le cas pour giovanni l'aironi ici
antenne 2 nous sommes toujours très
attentif à tout ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté des alpes
car nombreux sont les italiens qui nous
capter qui nous suivent et je crois
qu'il serait assez inélégant de se
repaître des seuls malheur des italiens
car après tout malgré une nuit des
difficultés rome nous donne encore une
assez jolie leçon de démocratie de sens
critique et de réactions intellectuelle
il est vrai que pour beaucoup de
français j'en suis sûr l'italie
aujourd'hui surtout après bon cette
histoire les rené moreau c'est un pays à
feu et à sang c'est un pays en pleine
déliquescence secondes l'allemand épuisé
bien au derrière ce désordre évident je
crois qu'il y à une autre réalité un peu
paradoxal et qu'il faut connaître aussi
c'est que il règne en italie encore
aujourd'hui un dynamisme et une
créativité tout à fait extraordinaire
dans le domaine par exemple du cinéma
c'est évident
tout le monde le sait le cinéma italien
est un des premiers du monde je crois
qu'on peut le dire mais également dans
le domaine du théâtre dans le domaine de
la musique de la littérature il y à un
bouillonnement absolument fantastique
mais il n'ya pas que dans le domaine
culturel
et d'ailleurs c'est pas la première fois
en italie parce que rappelez vous la
grande renaissance italienne
15e siècle c'est une période de cent et
de fureur c'est une période de troubles
effroyable la période des médicis la
période des borgia mais aussi de
botticelli de michel-ange extraits que
celle à gérer s'il semble économiques
intéressantes
alors il ya aussi une créativité bon
alors les français savent bien dans le
domaine du désign d'humeur
des chaussures des vêtements là on sait
bien que les italiens ont un très grand
dynamisme sont très présents sur le
marché mais également regarder la le
domaine des petits ordinateurs de
précision et bien olivetti et très
exportateur le domaine aussi de la
petite rue de la petite à siri bon vous
savez que pratiquement tout le béton
français 1 est armé avec des ronds de
béton qui viennent de ces petits hauts
fourneaux vous savez qu'ils prolifèrent
là bas en italie
la machine outil aussi est très
compétitive et puis il faut savoir que
fiat après un moment d'hésitation est en
train de réinvestir massivement en
italie or voilà un aspect italien qu'il
faut connaître
et puis enfin dernier paradoxe quand un
pays traverse une période comme ça de
trouble quand il est agressé par les
terroristes de tous bords sa tendance
vous le savez bien ce serait dire c'est
de de chercher les solutions d'or
d'autorité et de fuir un peu la solution
démocratique
or l'italie qui traverse cette période
depuis 10 ans reste quand même un des
pays les plus démocratiques du monde et
ça je crois qu'il faut le dire on vient
dans nos cordes en avoir la preuve
mais pour terminer par un sourire ya
aussi le football qui là bas aussi
marche très bien
autres voisins en crise la belgique le
roi baudouin demandé à l'otan de manse
de tenter un nouvel effort en vue de
résoudre cette crise où s'enchevêtrent
une fois de plus problèmes linguistiques
et économiques
aujourd'hui le souverain a consulté les
chefs de partis et à l'issue de ces
entretiens a maintenu monsieur kingdom
ans dans ses fonctions de premier
ministre le roi m'a demandé de tenter un
nouvel effort en vue de résoudre la
crise politique alors qu'elle et vous
essayez de faire là je vais maintenant
développé une méthode afin de pouvoir
prendre les contacts nécessaires et
méthodes qui doit me permettre donc de
conclure dans l'un ou l'autre chance
vous rayer ce qu'il pourrait y avoir un
remaniement ministériel il n'en est pas
question pour l'instant on m'a demandé
donc d'éviter une crise politique
enfin troisième grand pays menacé de
créer d'israël
la maladie de begin qui n'était un
secret pour personne de faux - il a été
hospitalisé accentue un malaise
politique à tel-aviv pour la première
fois depuis un an depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir il se sentant en minorité sur
une question cruciale
l'avenir la cisjordanie l'avenir de la
cisjordanie pourrait bien faire tomber
en effet monsieur begin et son
gouvernement
monsieur begin et ses partisans estiment
que l'autonomie administrative sous
contrôle israélien doit être maintenue
en cisjordanie après les cinq années
prévues ses adversaires pensent que la
cisjordanie doit avoir à nouveau statut
dans l'avenir qui impliqua dégagement
israélien c'est la tendance souple
représentée par monsieur est réservé aux
mânes ministre de la défense le général
dyan lui peut apparaître comme un
conciliateur
il propose que la jordanie soit associé
à la deuxième phase de l'autonomie
jamais depuis un an monsieur béguines ne
s'est trouvé dans une telle impasse
mais en cas de démission il devrait
normalement se succéder à lui même
selon a fini avec l'étranger quand je
vous aurais dit que le dernier para
français a quitté la iie guerre comme
l'avait annoncé le président de la
république
et puis que le reste de cette actualité
internationale et bien vous allez la
voir en images
elle est tout à la fois tragiques
souriante et d'abord diplomatique
le roi juan carlos d'espagne est arrivé
ce matin à pékin pour une visite
officielle de cinq jours la première
visite en chine d'un chef d'état
espagnols huecco feng le premier chinois
thank you ping vice premier ministre ont
serré la main du roi et de la reine
sofia leur descente d'avion de l'avion
spécial d'iberia frappé aux armoiries de
la maison royale
la presse officielle béninoise est
l'organe du parti communiste chinois
salué avec enthousiasme l'arrivée du
souverain espagnol qualifié de véritable
européen
victoire de l'écologie aux états unis à
cause de ce petit poisson de 7 cm de
long baptisé oxo d'escargots la
construction d'un barrage sur le fleuve
leeds d'hennessy va être abandonné
l'ouvragé détruit environ 500 millions
de francs qui partent en fumée
ainsi en a décidé la cour suprême car il
a été démontré que l'édification de cet
ouvrage risquait de faire disparaître
définitivement la taupe soit escargots
une espèce rarissime
istanbul un autobus tombe dans le
bosphore avec 40 personnes à bord
l'accident s'est produit cette nuit cinq
rescapés ont réussi à quitter le
véhicule à la nage les hommes
grenouilles sont parvenus à repérer
l'autobus qui reposait à 40 nettes de
fonds et qui a pu être remontée avec sa
tragique cargaison le premier dossier
français que nous allons ouvrir
maintenant ensemble c'est celui la peine
de mort car profitant d'une relative
accalmie dans la vie politique du pays
profitant aussi de l'absence de tout
faits divers tragiques qui pourraient
dramatiser le débat une poignée de
députés relance l'abolition de la peine
de mort ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils appartiennent à des formations
politiques très diverses
le rpr comme le parisien pierre basse le
ps le breton alain chénard maire de
nantes où l'udf comme bernard stasi qui
explique la raison est le but de cette
proposition de loi
nous l'avons déposé dès le début de la
présente législature
en espérant que ce débat pourra venir le
plus tôt possible avant l'apprennent
parlement avant la fin de l'année avant
la fin de l'année de jesper les français
sont préoccupés par la violence qu'ils
ont raison et ils considèrent dans leur
grande majorité et sur ce point je ne
suis pas en accord avec eux que la peine
de mort et à des moyens efficaces de
lutter contre cette violence de faire
reculer la violence
nous sommes un certain nombre à penser
que c'est une idée reçue que ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité et je crois
que dans certains problèmes de
conscience comme celui ci il ne veut pas
hésité à aller à contre-courant à
prendre des positions qui ne
correspondent pas à la position de la
majorité de l'opinion et vous allez
faire quoi pour convaincre ces français
vous
le débat parlementaire contribuerait à
éclairer les françaises parce que nous
considérons que c'est une tare pour
notre pays qui est civilisée pour notre
société qui se dit humaniste que de
conserver encore dans son arsenal cette
peine de mort qui a été rejetée par la
plupart des pays européens sauf par la
russie et par l'albanie et récemment par
l'espagne qui considérait la peine de
mort comme un vestige du franquisme
alors aussitôt nous avons cherché à
savoir ce qu'en pense est un homme
politique et le garde des sceaux
d'abord bien sûr parce qu'il est
ministre de la justice mais aussi parce
qu'il ya deux ans il s'était
personnellement déclaraient hostiles à
la peine de mort c'est une chose de
déposer une proposition de loi signée
par une dizaine de parlementaires et
c'est autre chose
d'entraîner la majorité les
parlementaires sont les traducteurs
naturel de l'opinion publique s'il
considère qu'il ya une évolution
suffisant de l'opinion publique
s'ils considèrent qu'il faut passer
outre à l'opinion publique et bien c'est
à eux de prendre leurs responsabilités
cela dit je pense que le dépôt de cette
proposition de loi devrait donner lieu à
de nouveau sondage pour voir si
l'opinion publique qui s'étaient montrés
réfractaires à l'abolition de la peine
de mort il ya encore deux ans a changé
depuis lors et puis peut-être pour
engager un débat national sur cette
affaire
philosophiquement je ne souhaite pas que
demers est certainement cette peine de
mort mais que dans les circonstances
présentes tant que le sentiment
d'insécurité est grand chez les français
le moment n'est pas surpris par la
démarche des députés le ministre de la
justice ajoute est parmi les magistrats
de l'union syndicales réunies en congrès
à strasbourg qu'il serait peut-être
difficile d'obtenir sur ce projet ce que
l'on appelle une majorité d'idées
car si on a tout écrit et tout dit sur
la peine de mort personne ici parmi les
membres de la magistrature ne vais faire
de prévisions sur le vote possible des
parlementaires mais il n'est pas
indifférent d'ajouter que beaucoup de
juges son paravent satisfait ou curieux
d'entendre enfin poser ainsi une telle
question qui avaient jusqu alors la
triste habitude d'occuper l'essentiel
des débats sur la justice quant aux
opinions personnelles manifester
aujourd'hui par quelques-uns
les membres de l'union syndicale
présidée par andré borschberg via le
mans semblait rejoindre le souhait
abolitionniste la politique pure
maintenant avec la réception à l'elysée
de alain polaire et de l'ensemble du
bureau de l'association des maires de
france
avec aussi la conclusion provisoire d'un
conflit qui oppose l'état et la ville de
paris
l'ultime démarche de jacques chirac n'a
pas abouti s'il se voit donc contraint
de demander des impôts supplémentaires
pour les parisiens l'année prochaine
plus 7% l'appliquent de christian bonnet
le ministre de l'intérieur les parisiens
n'ont pas à supporter des impôts
nouveaux
pour que la ville puisse se faire face
aux dépenses de police à paris
avec enfin la première journée du
conseil national du ceni a lyon les
indépendants s'interroge pour savoir
s'ils doivent entrer ou non dans l'udf
l'attend semble prévaloir pour l'instant
bertrand motte le président et camille
laurens se fait en général ont rendu
hommage à la politique de redressement
économique de raymond barre qui
assistait d'ailleurs à leurs travaux et
qui leur a parlé de la nécessaire
entente de la majorité je considère que
je dois sauvegarder protéger et faire
fructifier
l'entente majoritaire car c'est
l'entente majoritaire qui permet au
gouvernement d'exercer l'action
nécessaire au service de la france
l'entente
je souhaite donc comme que compte tenu
des différences normales entre les
formations qui constituent la majorité
celle ci met points seulement l'idée de
cultiver leur différence mais plutôt de
faire apparaître leur personnalité dans
le cadre de l'entente majoritaire à
montbard qui sera notre invité à cartes
sur table 22 juin alain duhamel et jean
pierre elkabbach l'interrogeons en
direct de pau à l'issue d'un voyage
effectifs officielle dans les pyrénées
atlantiques
pendant ce temps au sénat le
gouvernement s'est fait interpeller par
l'opposition à propos de sa politique en
afrique et à l'assemblée le débat sur la
défense s'est achevée sans grande
passion cette nuit dans sa dernière
intervention yvon bourges le ministre a
rappelé que son devoir était de
maintenir l'armée en dehors des débats
politiques il n'y a plus de déléguée à
la condition féminine jacqueline nos
noms qui avait remplacé monique
pelletier a démissionné les raisons de
sa démission ne sont guère précisé elle
pense avoir plus de moyens d'action en
retravaillant comme elle l'avait fait
auparavant pendant longtemps à bruxelles
elle était alors chargé des problèmes de
l'emploi des femmes
et si elle retrouve son poste en
septembre elle aura du pain sur la
planche car les femmes qui sont de plus
en plus nombreuses à chercher un emploi
ce qui n'était pas le cas il ya encore
cinq ans on est encore beaucoup plus de
difficultés pour les hommes il y a une
véritable discrimination
nous devons en ce qui concerne le
salaire à travail égal salaire égal
la formule est belle mais ne correspond
pas à la réalité
voyez ces tableaux un cap supérieur
femmes touchent en moyenne 6300 francs
par mois contre 10 mille francs pour un
homme différence de 37%
une ouvrière spécialisée gagne 1930
francs tandis qu'à travail égal
l'homme gagne 2500 50 francs différence
24%
en gros l'écart entre le salaire
masculin et féminin est d'environ 30%
depuis 1972 la loi et c'est vers la
discrimination à l'embauché fondée sur
le sexe est assimilée à celle fondée sur
la race ou la religion
elle prévoit de même des peines
d'emprisonnement pourtant très peu
d'affaires vont en justice
actuellement le plus nos sont saisis de
seulement six plaintes
je ferai une analogie rythme racisme
comment pouvez vous démontrer qu'on ne
vous a pas louer tel appartement parce
que vous étiez noir ou blanc ou jaune ou
rouge
bon l'employeur pourra toujours dire ce
n'est pas parce que c'est une femme si
parce que l'autre à des qualifications
des qualités supérieures je m'entends
mieux avec l'homme que la femme
aujourd'hui plus de 8 millions de femmes
travaillent elles représentent donc 37 %
de la population active
la plupart du temps elles sont cantonnés
au plus bas niveau mais même pour celles
qui atteignent des postes de
responsabilité les ennuis ne sont pas
signés j'étais dans une société depuis
27 ans j'ai créé un service il y a deux
ans un service exportations les
résultats ont
on est en positif en représentant a été
embauché et ce monsieur a pris la place
de chef d' agences qui aurait dû me
revenir de droit après une discussion
avec le directeur
on a nettement dit que c'est parce que
c'était un homme et que le choix a été
fait parce que c'était un homme et pour
quelles raisons et bien parce que les
hommes n'acceptent pas de recevoir des
ordres des femmes à présent madame luce
fait un procès à son ex employeur
mais la discrimination n'est jamais
facile à prouver
les employeurs font preuve d'une
imagination débordante pour ce domaine
en effet
ils pourront donner une prime
supplémentaire à un homme en lui
accordant une toute petite
responsabilité supplémentaire
ils pourront également donner à la femme
une qualification inférieure à l'emploi
qu'elle s'est en réalité en file tout un
arsenal de façon qui permette de se
rémunérer les femmes par rapport à leurs
qualifications 7 ans se sont écoulés
combien faudra-t-il encore d'année pour
expliquer aux femmes leurs droits et aux
hommes leur devoir chef de l'état avait
abordé le problème dans sa dernière
conférence de presse il avait souligné
qu'il s'agissait bien plus d'un problème
de moeurs que de loi renault la
direction de la régie a annoncé
aujourd'hui que l' usine de flins serait
fermée la semaine prochaine si le
travail ne reprenait pas l'atelier des
grandes presse de son côté le tribunal
de versailles a donné 48 heures aux
grévistes pour évacuer l'atelier et
demande parallèlement à la direction
d'ouvrir des négociations
un salarié sur quatre halles usines
moulinex d'alençon est en grève avec
occupation de lusine le juge a décidé de
nommer un médiateur
le moral des patrons heureusement qu'ils
sont plus optimistes sur la situation
économique il ya quatre mois c'est ce
que nous révèle un sondage louis harris
publiée dans l'express
mais les français d'une manière générale
sont plus inquiets ils craignent pour
leur pouvoir d'achat
françois ceyrac sera notre invité demain
dans samedi je m'attends vous raconter
une histoire histoire d'amour au départ
mais qui depuis a sombré dans le mystère
médiévale de nîmes à skis nos un jeune
français de 23 ans rencontrent une
algérienne
dalila la famille de dalila musulmane
est opposée au mariage
les amoureuses mari quand même en france
puis s'installe au canada et c'est là
qu'intervient un personnage à la volonté
farouche homme d'affaires très puissant
en algérie conseiller personnel du
président boumédiène c'est le frère de
dany là il est violemment opposés à ce
mariage
il va jusqu'à se rendre lui aussi au
canada pour amadouer de coupe et soudain
c'est le drame et le 24 mai dernier
dalila comme souvent le faisait d'aller
dîner je suis son frère et ses soeurs
n'est pas revenu ces 24 heures après que
denis l'a appris et il a pris il y avait
des témoins et puis une enquête de
police canadienne depuis l'a confirmé il
a appris que dalila au cours de ce repas
a été drogué il a été transporté
dans une chaise comme une infirme à
l'aéroport où l'attendaient des c8 privé
que messaoud zeggar avait loué et c'est
ainsi qu'elle a été kidnappée qu'elle a
rejoint le jury
depuis cette date le gouvernement
canadien une fois qu'il enquête a montré
là qu'il y avait eu enlèvement a déposé
une plainte
saisie plus exactement les autorités
algériennes les autorités algériennes
ont répondu qu'elle s'occuperait de la
faire
alors justement qu'est-ce qui pourrait
dénouer la faire une algérienne une
musulmane plus exactement ne peut
épouser que musulman par conséquent le
mariage de dalila en algérie n'est pas
valable
mais c'est pourquoi lé et les re
mariable en quelque sorte mariam et
c'est ce qu'il attend la fin du mois
dalila est aujourd'hui absolument
désespérée et les malades et ce qu'il
faut faire dans un premier temps s'était
même pas obtenir ça serait trop beau sa
liberté mais simplement qu'ils puissent
vivre s car sa vie est en danger
je voudrais surtout pas que ce qui vient
d'arriver à dalila servent à une espèce
de rejet systématique et raciste tout ce
qui est arabe ou algérien il y à de
nombreux algériens qui sont tous prêts à
faire eux aussi quelque chose pour que
dalila redevienne une femme libre m
denise thouanel mise en liberté elle
avait été inculpée pour sortie
irrégulière de correspondance selon lui
reprochait d'avoir outrepassé son rôle
d'avocat est donc ce soir en liberté
mais sous contrôle judiciaire
une nouvelle citroën la visa elle se
situe entre le bas de gamme style de
chevaux et et puis la js est une cinq
portes à traction avant vous voyez à ces
petites avec deux versions 4 chevaux
cinq chevaux et trois finitions
possibles avantage une faible
consommation
la catastrophe de l'amoco cadiz malgré
de très beaux efforts n'a pas fini de
nettoyer les plages en bretagne et on
commence à faire les comptes
achat de produits des polluants
indemnisation tout cela coûte très cher
à ce jour la facture s'élève à plus de
300 millions de francs
ce chiffre comprend le coût du plan
polmar c'est à dire l'organisation des
secours à terre et en mer
22 millions de francs pour les 47
bâtiments de la marine nationale engagés
dans la lutte anti pollution et 50
millions de francs pour les dépenses de
l'armée de terre il faut compter
également plus de 100 millions pour les
entreprises françaises et étrangères qui
participent aux différentes phases du
nettoyage ne sont pas comprises dans ce
total les dépenses en produits déversés
dans la zone souillée
alors à ce qui n'est encore qu'une
estimation
il faut ajouter le coût des
indemnisations des gens de la mer
pêcheurs ostréiculteurs goémoniers soit
sur trois mois près de 3000 personnes
indemnisées pour un montant de 5
millions de francs + l'indemnisation des
professions liées aux touristes un
manque à gagner qui ne pourra être
apprécié qu'en fin de saison mais déjà
pour les mois de mai et de juin il y a
eu 60 % de fréquentation en moins que
l'an dernier
alors si vous additionnez tous ces
chiffres vous obtenez près de 300
millions de francs 3 milliards de
centimes et ce n'est là que la partie
visible de l'iceberg car c'est au
minimum par cinq qu'il faudra multiplier
cette somme est ce ce thème je vous
conseille la lecture de la mère
assassinée de marie-josée jaubert paris
aux éditions alain moreau puis d'une
série de brochures éditées par ouest
france notamment sur les régions
touchées et sur les marais qui sont
d'une grande importance écologique et
qui souvent ont été touchés par la marée
noire
j'en profite aussi puisque nous sommes
vendredi sur la postroff pour vous
conseiller un autre livre celui de
françois gros sur les nouveaux
syndicaliste un nouveau président pour
la société des gens de lettres didier
decoin ce sera donc un jeune président
dernière page de ce journal la météo
pour demain un temps à peu près
identique à celui d'aujourd'hui médiocre
et frais on observera des publi
passagère et des averses orageuses sur
la provence les alpes et les régions de
l'est
ailleurs le temps sera plus variable
mais généralement nuageux avec quelques
averses et des éclaircies et des
températures resteront faibles
peu de changements pour dimanche aux
environs de 22 heures 50 patrick lecocq
vous présentera le dernier journal je
vous rappelle que demain vous avez un
rendez-vous à 12h30 pour samedi demi
avec françois ceyrac quant à raymond
barre nous le recevrons bien le jeudi 20
2 à bayonne et non pas pour comme je
vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure pour cartes
sur table quant à moi et bien je vous
souhaite un très bon week-end je vous
retrouve avec plaisir lundi au revoir
à